This episode is sponsored by Squarespace.
Go to Squarespace.com/microcosmos to save
10% off your first purchase of a website or domain.
A useful principle in the story of life is
that you should never underestimate algae
or cyanobacteria.
They will always manage to surprise you,
and more importantly, to remind you that everything
you have, ultimately comes down to them.
Do you like oxygen?
Well, take some time to thank a cyanobacterium.
If their ancestors hadn’t gone a little
haywire with their photosynthesis and set
off the Great Oxidation Event billions of
years ago, we would not exist.
But you don’t even have to look back into
history to see the influence of
algae and cyanobacteria.
Today, even algae of the smallest size have
a tremendous impact on our lives,
both good and bad.
On one hand, they translate sunlight into
food through photosynthesis.
On the other hand, they bloom in waters and
release toxins that can wreak damage on the
organisms around them.
But the real reason you should never underestimate
algae or cyanobacteria is because at their
core, they are organisms that seem to just
always find a way.
They exist in super salty waters, in ponds,
in hot springs.
Though, these are of course aquatic organisms, and
so you might think of their adaptations as restricted
to watery environments.
But what has made algae so capable of existing
beyond those boundaries is their willingness
to use other organisms as a means to their
own survival.
At times, their symbiotic relationships sound
absurd, like the species that makes a home
out of sloth fur.
But our favorite example of the creativity
that algae and cyanobacteria approach their
relationships with has to be lichen—
that combination of fungus and algae, or fungus
and cyanobacteria, that attaches to trees
and rocks and anything else that sits around
long enough.
The concept of a lichen appears simple enough.
There’s a fungus, which has an incredible
capacity for spreading and decomposing, but
no means to make its own food.
And there’s the algae or cyanobacteria,
fully capable of making their own food, but
in need of some help getting around on land.
The result is called a dual organism, made
up of the fungal mycobiont and the algal photobiont
that takes on the spreading qualities of the
first, and the colors of the second.
Fungi and algae can meet and work together
in ways that actually don’t result in a lichen.
The distinct structure that we associate with
lichens comes down to the thallus, made up
of distinct layers that reveal the different
combinations of the organisms that make it.
The thallus is what allows lichens to survive,
keeping the organism alive in dry conditions
so it can tolerate extremes in humidity and
temperature.
The shape is generally a function of the fungus,
which starts to weave its body into the appropriate
layers as soon as it comes upon algae to team
up with.
At the edge is the cortex, where fungal cells
are thicker and close in contact so they can
form a protective structure.
And beneath, it keeps a more fibrous and loose
mass of hyphae, a scaffolding structure called
the medulla that the photobionts layer themselves
on, dividing and creating their own algal
layer that’s large and green and positioned
to access the sun.
That layer of cells tells us a little bit more about
the organisms inside the lichen, though only
under the right conditions.
A dry lichen is typically gray.
But with water, the fungal gray clears up,
revealing the color of the photobionts inside
the lichen.
In the case of algae photobionts, you’ll
typically see a bright green color.
But when there are cyanobacteria, the hues
vary from dark green to black.
Now lichens have to actually stick to the
thing they are stuck to,
and they have a few ways to anchor
themselves onto surfaces.
Some have a structure called a holdfast that
extends as part of the thallus, a bit like
a peg that is very good at holding on to things
like rock.
Our lichen here though uses a different type of
structure called rhizines.
These are threads that come from the medulla
or lower cortex, creeping out from the lichen
like roots, only they do not have any
capacity to draw in nutrients.
They are just anchors.
Now from our perspective right now, there’s
nothing controversial about this partnering of
fungus and algae.
We look in the lichen, we see signs of both
organisms, and we boil it down to a simple
exchange of protection for food.
This ancient relationship brought algae onto
land and into places so different from their
watery origins.
But our understanding of lichens as not just
one organism, but two is actually relatively recent,
going back only to 1867, when a Swiss botanist
named Simon Schwendener presented his work
at the Swiss Natural History Society.
He’d been looking at lichen under the microscope,
just as we are now, when he considered the possibility
that the mass of hyphae he was looking at
belonged to a fungus, wrapped around algae.
His contemporary lichenologists did not agree.
Sure, Schwendener was just one of multiple
scientists who had noted a resemblance between
the parts of lichen, and the bodies of fungi
and algae.
But that was just a resemblance, it seemed
to the lichenologists at the time.
In their defense, they did not know that
a dual organism could exists,
They did not know that there was a symbiosis here
How could they, when the word symbiosis
hadn’t been invented yet?
Schwendener had more reasons than just appearances
though.
One challenge that lichenologists repeatedly
came across was that it was impossible to
grow a new lichen from isolating either the
spores or the green cells growing within the lichen.
But in 1877, a scientist named Albert Bernhard
Frank came up with the term “symbiosis.”
The organism that inspired him to come up
with that word?
Well of course., it was lichen.
Frank was one of several biologists intrigued
by the possibility of Schwendener’s hypothesis,
this idea that organisms could live together,
not just in an environment, but in one entity.
Now with time, lichenologists came around, and
people only uncovered more examples and nuances
around symbiosis.
But that does not mean that we
actually understand lichen.
They remain challenging to cultivate in a
lab, and we’re still understanding whether
the symbiosis we’ve reduced to a simple
meeting of two organisms might  actually more
complex—whether it can involve other species
as well.
Perhaps there’s a way to describe lichens
and the world inside of them that we just
don’t know yet, a word that, like symbiosis,
will reveal something new and remarkable to
us about our world.
The way we talk about science and knowledge
sometimes makes it feel like we’re done,
that science is a static set of all of the facts
in the universe,
because it is a lot easier to talk about the things
that we know than the things that we don’t.
Of course it’s hard to talk about the things
that we don't know, because we don't know them.
But our world is always there, containing
the information that we want in everyday
occurrences that are sometimes hundreds
of millions of years old,
we humans just have to figure out ways to
ask the questions that will actually give us answers.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thanks to Squarespace for sponsoring
this episode.
Squarespace gives people a powerful and beautiful
online platform from which to create their website.
So whether you’re looking to create an online
portfolio, start a blog, or open an online
store, Squarespace can help you out.
Maybe it’s finally time to start that photography
blog you’ve been thinking about.
Well, Squarespace has the tools you need.
They make it super simple to categorize, schedule
and share your blog posts.
And once your blog takes off, you’re going
to want to connect with your audience,
and guess what?
Squarespace can help you out there as well.
You can interact with your community on your
Squarespace site through threaded comments
and replies, and can even generate extra revenue
through members-only content.
And if you decide you want to start selling
prints of your fantastic photos, well, you
already know what I’m going to say, Squarespace
can help you out there as well.
Squarespace is already a powerful ecommerce
platform, but you can even go the extra mile
and add third-party extensions to help you
manage inventory, streamline bookkeeping,
and ship products across the world.
And you can do all of this on one easy-to-use
platform.
So go to Squarespace.com to sign up for a
free trial, and when you’re ready to launch,
go to squarespace.com/microcosmos to save
10% off your first purchase of a website or domain.
The folks on the screen right now, they are
our Patreon patrons.
They're the people who make it possible for
me to sit here at my desk and just be absolutely
amazed and astounded by the completely invisible
beauty of our world that we can only see and
understand because of the extremely hard work
of literally millions of people from the very
first microscopist until now.
I'm so glad that we get to make this show.
And if you want to help us out, you can do
that by going to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.